this is a cut
this is a
housewarm it's like being fired or
thrown out
i felt like i was being slammed against
a glass wall one of my colleagues
described it like being thrown from a
moving train that's a pretty good
description it's not easy excuse me
i've been a professional politician for
18 years in that time i've moved away
from my career working for an ngo in
bilifead i can't go back to that job to
that field
i always knew that being a member of
parliament was a risk
i'm getting a one-month transitional
allowance for every year i was in
parliament and that's it
and that goes to july 1st
that's true that's lovely
i miss the political work i miss it a
lot it's like going into withdrawal
i'm a medical instructor by profession
and a nurse
those are jobs that are in high demand
i'm lucky i've been able to step right
back into my family's company
for many of my colleagues everything's
still up in the air
they still don't know what they're going
to do after the transitional allowance
runs out
it's a real problem for them
to me and i want to keep playing an
active role i don't like other people
making decisions for me municipal
elections are coming up here in
saxonyonhalt i'd like to get back on the
local council
for anyone in business going into
politics is risky they can't know what
will happen to them afterwards that's
the big question
that's what keeps many middle class
people from going into politics for four
years or eight years
right now it's just too big of a hurdle
what would certainly help is if the
party the parliamentary groups would
commit to taking care of their former
members of parliament
i found that former members of
parliament are no longer welcome in
ordinary jobs to be a member of
parliament you have to be a bit of a
show-off
and even more importantly we can see
through all those power relationships we
know what's behind the curtains
so ordinary employers aren't really that
keen to have us around they're worried
we'll shake up the entire system
i'm not sure i'd really want to go back
there's
i'm not part of this anymore and that's
okay
i can watch what's going on and i know
exactly what it feels like but i'm on
the outside looking in and that's
exactly how it should be that's reality
in the reality